اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات
المسجد الاقصى للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه
واعتدت على المصلين قبل انتهاء صلاه
التراويح امس الاربعاء وخلال عمليه
اخلائها المسجد من المصلين والمعتكفين
اطلقت قوات الاحتلال الرصاصه المطاطي على
المصلين والموجودين في باحاته وبعد
انسحابها من الباحات ابقت قوات الاحتلال
وجودها عند الابواب المؤديه الى المسجد
كما فرضت قيودا على دخول المسجد الاقصى
لاداء صلاه الفجر وامنعت الرجال دون
الاربعين عاما من الدخول
كما اقتحمت مجموعات من المستوطنين باحات
المسجد الاقصى مجددا تحت حمايه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
معنى من جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان اهلا بك كيف هي
الاوضاع هذا الصباح ده
نعم حاليا الاوضاع هادئه لكن هدوء يعني
يشوبه الحذر يمكن القول حاليا في هذه
الاثناء يمكن رؤيه هذه المجموعه الثانيه
من المستوطنين التي
اقتحمت المسجد الاقصى
المبارك قبل قليل راينا المجموعه الاولى
من هنا من منطقه جبل الزيتون مع بدء هذه
الاقتحامات بحراسه مشدده من شرطه الاحتلال
قوات كبيره من عناصر شرطه الاحتلال
اقتحموا اولا المسجد الاقصى المبارك بحدود
الساعه السابعه صباحا بتوقيت مدينه القدس
وانتشروا في الباحات تامينا لهذه
الاقتحامات وبعدها تم فتح باب المغاربه
المخصص لهذه الاقتحامات وبدينا نرى هذه
المجموعات تقتحم المسجد الاقصى
مبارك لكن قبل ذلك عند اذان الفجر تم منع
اعداد كبيره من المصلين من الدخول الى
المسجد الاقصى المبارك لاداء صلاه الفجر
اعداد قليله جدا تمكنت من الدخول والصلاه
واداء صلاه الفجر هذا اليوم لليوم الثاني
على التوالي مع بدء عيد الفصح اليهودي
اعداد كبيره صلت عند الابواب قبل قليل
قابلنا احد الشبان ممن وصلوا من منطقه
بعيده من الشمال خصيصا لاداء صلاه الفجر
لكن اخبرنا بانه منع من ذلك وعناصر من
شرطه الاحتلال عند الابواب كانت في كل مره
تغير
العمر او الجيل الذي يسمح له بالدخول بعد
في بعض الاحيان يقولون انه يسمح فقط لمن
هم فوق سن الاربعين واحيانا كانوا يقولون
بانه يسمح فقط لمن هم فوق الخمسه
وبالتالي لم يسمح لاعداد كبيره في الدخول
الى المسجد من الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وحاليا يوجد عدد قليل من المصلين
في الداخل حتى انه لم يسمح لهم باداء صلاه
الضحى بعد صلاه الفجر وهو عاده يقومون
بتاديه هذه الصلاه في المسار الذي يمر منه
المستوطنون وراينا يوم امس كيف تم تفريق
المصلين اثناء اداء هذه الصلاه من قبل
شرطه الاحتلال
ربما هذا اليوم هو اليوم الاول رسميا لعيد
الفصح الذي يستمر لاسبوع هو بمثابه يوم
عطله رسمي ايام السبت
ومن المتوقع بطبيعه الحال خلال هذا
الاسبوع ان تكون هناك اعداد كبيره
للمقتحمين من المستوطنين والمتطرفين
اليهود هناك دعوات واسعه من قبل هذه
المنظمات التي تطلق على نفسها منظمات
الهيكل او عائدون الى الهيكل الى تكثيف
هذه الاقتحامات خلال هذه
الفتره تحديدا بدايه الاسبوع المقبل فيما
يعرف بيوم صلاه الكهنه في هذا العيد لديهم
وايضا رغم كل هذا التوتر ما زالوا يدعون
ايضا الى محاولات تقديم القرابين في محيط
المسجد الاقصى المبارك راينا هناك محاولات
يوم امس لعدد من المتطرفين والمستوطنين
الوصول الى منطقه المسجد الاقصى الى
البحات وفي محيطه وهم يحاولون تقديم
القرابين والذبائح في هذا العيد من جهه
اخرى هناك انتشار واسع لشرطه الاحتلال في
محيط البلده القديمه بالاضافه الى ازقه
البلده القديمه وايضا عند ابواب المسجد
الاقصى المبارك انتشار مكثف ووا لتامين
هذه الاقتحامات ولتامين احتفالات اليهود
بهذا العيد في المقابل هناك اغلاق شامل
على منطقه الضف باقي الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه عمليا تم الاعلان منذ عده ايام بان
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سيحكم الحصار على
باقي ارجاء الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه خلال
ايام هذا العيد وسيتم التجديد على
المعابر والحواجز العسكريه اذا هذا هو
الوضع حاليا في المسجد الاقصى بعد ليله
ثانيه كانت ايضا عصيبه على المسجد الاقصى
بسبب اقتحامات شرطه الاحتلال وتفريغ
المسجد من كافه المصلين والمعتكفين بعد
صلاه التراويح اجوان سمري شكرا جزيلا لك